i'm dora amari who has left officially
the new york post after about a decade
he's building his own media empire how's
that going field in the media empire
i've never had to do payroll before
suddenly i've always been an employee
now this new reality but it's enjoyable
it's very exciting yeah so what exactly
are you working on sure so it's i am
doing it with two other partners some of
us come from the uh the right and some
of us come from a more uh leftist milieu
and we want to critique both the
existing left and right because i think
they both failed and to maybe try to
forge a new
fusion and what this conference is about
is trying to piece this thing together
so i guess in the broadest sense do you
think it's even possible to do it
i think a new
kind of
coalition has to
has to emerge i've used the term the new
right
and that includes traditional
conservatives it includes
a
nationalist a national conservative it
includes a kind of pure trumpian
populist as well and i would even add uh
various people exiled from the left all
these people um you know we're not going
to agree on everything we but we share a
critique something isn't working there
is a dystopian
quality to life in the united states and
across the west
and i think it tends to work for
an elite
it increasingly doesn't work for
ordinary people they want economic
stability they want a measure of
cultural normality i would say
and i think out of that it is possible
you can you know ferociously disagree
about what comes next and out of that
a thoughtful engagement possible to
forge a new coalition so the elements
are there as someone that comes from the
more religious side of this how do you
say to the purely secular people
you can fit it i think it's something
that
you said dave at your remarks here
earlier where you said
that freedom without
the sense of what are we for
um has left here an idea of the kind of
liberalism
that
rejects any kind of
moral authority or any accounts what
makes people happy
a society where people float you reject
that um you get a you go down a dark
place and ideologies like localism in a
way are prepared to
take their place because both of them it
has a moral account now you and i think
it's a
correct account right but it is a moral
video and so it cannot be met with near
individual rights type discourse it has
to be met with a truer account of who
the person is and religious
conservatives
play a role in that
and they can play a role with that not
spray drawing on revelation but just
read alone right
reason as the classical
understood it has a much bigger account
okay who's the human person
how does he fit into a cosmos
that sort of stuff i think
again without bringing the bible into
the picture
is is where
you know seculars can meet
uh conservatives like me religiously
like me yeah are you shocked that it's
happening it seems like it really is
happening i mean the fact that you and i
find common cause in all of this people
would ask me this a few years ago when
things look especially um
uh uh well these continue to look
correct but actually like
what's what's gonna happen if do you
have any optimism and the answer i would
give is that the very miserableness of
our current
social economic arrangements
that will
awaken people because they will they
have to ask themselves there must be
something more to our common life it
can't can't just be this so
with the particular formation that it
took no i didn't know i couldn't predict
that but a sense that
um
some liberals some leftists
would break
i thought i saw that
so you live in new york yeah i live at
least for now in california we are here
in the free state of florida do you
sense that regardless of whether we can
put this coalition together or not that
the states are just going to keep
drifting apart which in many ways is
sort of how it's supposed to be that's
sort of what the founders wanted in in
some sense
see i i don't like that i don't like any
kind of
pseudo-secessionist thoughts i think i
didn't say i like it just
we have to aim
for
national power
um
they're not going to leave us alone in
states where for example the right
regime is more sane ultimately you know
they can
muscle through their will both at the
federal level but also because they
often their power is corporate power
it's private power
and so as long as they have that we
don't have a countervailing power so i i
just say you know
it's not going to last
either they're going to take over the
whole or we're going to take over the
hole right what do you make of this
virginia situation tomorrow i see this
as a huge bellwether moment like i it's
crazy that i have to care about a
virginia gubernatorial election it
shouldn't be that way but for the
purposes you're talking about it's sort
of all or nothing in a weird way um i
think this is huge huge it's like if we
can get a win here it signals to people
we're going to really push back against
critical race theory we're going to
start caring about
you know parents are allowed to care
about their kids again and if we don't
win it's just just more
ash on the heap right now
i think it's a very crucial race um
because
it will confirm this theory or not which
is
that that liberal as liberals in their
aggression went
uh pick one too many battles and pick
the battle where it's things are very
very sensitive and that is people's
children yeah even uh people who don't
think like me
don't like the thought of their kids
being targeted for gender ideology and
transitioning without them having a say
in it or being told that because of the
color of their skin they're inherently
either a victim or a
permanent oppressor class people don't
like that and
i think it is a good bet to think
that you know this is where the fight
back begins and it's so appropriate
because family children
are the fundamental unit of political
community and so in defending it you're
defending
the whole as it were so
do you want to make an official
prediction
no i'm not a prime minister i don't i
don't follow polls i have no idea all
right well i think we should leave it
there because we're going to pick this
up tonight for a good half hour so we
previewed our
discussion
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell